okay, quick summary of Renaissance,
that is 1500 to 1700
or 16th century to 18th century.
renaissance means rebirth,
the rebirth of classic text of old ideas.
and because the Gutenberg,
Gutenberg printing press, 1440,
a lot of books are able to be circulated
for the educated people to read and understand
and they began to be questioning
in a lot of galen's ideas.
so we start off with the Salius
Andreas Versalius,
who was professor of surgery and anatomy in Padua.
he allowed his students to do dissections on
human beings,
which hadn't happened before
that had all been dissections on Animals
because the Church had allowed dissections on
human beings.
his book was the on the Fabric of the Human Body
written in 1543.
he pointed out a number of galen's mistakes.
one of them
that there was no holes in the septum
and the other one
that the jawbone isn't made up of 2 bones,
just made up of one.
obviously Galen was only able to look at animals.
we then have William Harvey,
who taught that the blood circulated around the body
and he wrote his book
an Anatomical Account of the Motion of the
Heart and Blood
to publish this idea
and he identified the difference between the arteries
and the veins
and became hugely influential in that
he was doctor to the King.
we then have Thomas Sydenham,
who was an English doctor,
whilst we still have these ideas of the forehumers
carrying on
and people still believed in forehumers
and my asthma.
he started to talk about
actually observing the patient's symptoms,
writing them down,
recording them,
going to the patient's bedside
and observing them closely
and prescribing remedies that would actually
treat the disease
that weren't necessary
related to the 4
humours or 2
superstitious ideas
or religion.
and he was able to identify that
scarlet fever
and measles
were both very different diseases.
okay. so during this time period
we have the great Plague of 1665.
and you may well have a question
which ask you to make a comparison between that
and the Black Death of 1348.
okay. now this was horrendous
black Death in London.
sorry. the great plague in London.
um, killed about 100,000 people.
um, and there were now efforts made to a kind of
stop the control of disease
that weren't put in place
during the medieval times.
so households were locked up.
red crosses were painting on doors.
people were expected to
if they do be quarantined
for 40 days.
cats were killed and dogs.
the authorities also believe that you should have
and they pay people
to get rid of bodies from the streets.
and people started taking so
different treatments.
they started chewing tobacco,
which was a new plant
that come over from the Americas
because they thought that would help.
also they drank plague water,
which was something that was sold to them
by quack doctors.
ultimately these didn't help
because they
still didn't understand what was causing the plague,
but, you know,
people thought they did.